[Music]
this is death stranding to some this is
a 40 hour walking simulator unto others
it's a unique insight into the evolution
of mankind and the impending destruction
of the world it's story time once again
here on PlayStation granade he is death
stranding in a nutshell death stranding
opens up with key parts of the law acid
rain is falling but this rain does more
than burn it ages anything it touches
they call this time fall anyone caught
out in the rain without protection will
age in a matter of seconds scary stuff
those that do venture out eat these
things the only other living organisms
in the world crypto by oats which
slightly alleviate the effects of time
fall and assist in maintaining correct
blood levels yeah that does sound weird
so here's a better way to sum all that
up a crypto buyout a day keeps the time
fall away because of the weather
conditions nobody ever leaves the hub
bunker cities of the world giving rise
to the porters people brave or stupid
enough to walk to each location in the
USA dropping off supplies and parcels
one of these transporters is none other
than Sam Potter bridges our hero of the
story whose first mission is to take
medication to the President of the
United States herself easy to follow so
far well let's add to this over the last
49 years
strange anomalies have occurred allowing
tar covered dead beings to return to the
land of the living from crabs to
humanoid shapes to whales to whatever
the heck this thing is the law tells us
that these are BTS or beached things
which is quite literal dying in this
world leads to a limbo like place which
so happens to be a beach which traps the
dead before the afterlife so it's
literally like a purgatory and wouldn't
you have guessed it in our first jaunt
into the new world
Sam encounters a crew tasked with
burning bodies this process is
imperative as dead beings left to fester
for too long will necrotize and become
VTS but the fumes of burning bodies is
so toxic it can only be done at a mod
de crema Torian so Sam helps the guys
out and the black stuff hits the fan as
this mysterious man appears to summon
BTS
the crew realized this is the end an
attempt to kill themselves before the BT
can but what's with all this Harry Caray
well let's see what happens if a bt
consumes a human being everything goes
boom this is called the void out and
that's the end of the game thanks for
watching well luckily Sam has a
superhuman ability as he can survive
death he is a repatriate he simply finds
his body and he's back we don't
understand the baby inside him at this
point but we will at the end of the
video so let's crack on Sam makes it all
the way to the president and another
bombshell hits us president bridgett
strand is in fact Sam's mother bridget
is on her deathbed quite literally death
stranding likes to hit you in the face
with these metaphors for 40 hours
straight
president strands last wish is to
reconnect the United States and then
dies while she poorly convinces Sam to
help her out
Sam is immediately tasked with carrying
his dead mother to the local incinerator
but we've already seen why this is a
great idea to do ASAP so Sam burns his
mother's carcass and was also instructed
to incinerate a BB unit he was given in
the field this thing has a real baby
locked inside a false womb long story
short they found that removing a child
from a mother who had passed away
aka a still mother gives the baby the
ability to see both the living and the
dead making be B units imperative to
spotting BTS this unit is broken so Sam
is told to toss it in the garbage but
just before he does B T's show up and
some uses the faulty BB unit to escape
the area unharmed Sam and his new
partner returned to HQ and Sam still
isn't convinced about reconnecting
America so the game hits us with this
Sam sister a Malay who just so happens
to have been kidnapped on the other side
of America and he must save her and in
turn she will then be the next Donald
Trump I mean she will be the next
president but for all this to happen Sam
must first reconnect America hmm
something sounds fishy here long story
short Sam agrees begrudgingly
but not for America he's doing this for
his favorite sister Amelie and fYI the
criminal unit that took her away are
none other than the homo demons you can
make your own joke they're led by the
guy we saw earlier who can control be
teased happy days so off Sam drops on
his adventures using a piece of kit
known as a cupid to reconnect cities in
the US kind of like a futuristic
internet known as the chiral Network no
joke this is what you do for 30 hours
yeah it's not a game for everyone but
let's skip all that as the game
continues we slowly uncover details
about the world some people have a
condition called dooms
which allows them to travel to beaches
remember that's the in between life and
death
limbo sort of place Sam has class to
dooms which allows him to repatriate and
also he consent when BTS are around and
any the touch him cause this rash to
spread around his body due to this Sam
does not touch anyone he hates physical
contact higher levels of Doom's allow
sufferers to use the beach to instantly
travel around the world one such person
who has this is fragile who's a French
transporter who has an English name but
speaks with American vernaculars all
this is summed up with her catchphrase
Hanford Shia
the highest levels of Doom's allow
sufferers to summon and control be
teased the higher the level of Doom's
the bigger the BG's so everything is
pointing straight back to that
mysterious figure a really cool thing
happened from this moment forward every
time Sam reconnects with his BB they
share a memory together bb's past
visions of B B's father loving his child
stuck in his little chamber we'll get
back to that but just remember these
happen a lot and these are always
positive
midway through Sam's journey he finally
meets the golden masked man who reveals
himself as Higgs and like usual he
delivers a bad-guy monologue before
gifting us with a boss fight
here's another weird-ass piece of law to
remember
the weapons used to defeat beetee's use
sounds blood something within Sam allows
every secretion to be used as weaponry
so yeah that includes your urine and
poop weird just go with it all right so
I've introduced fragile without going
into depth so let's do that now
fragile is seen as a terrorist by most
people in the game this is because she
was responsible for transporting a bomb
into a city causing a void out just
outside but in a clever piece of
narrative symmetry we experienced the
same situation moments prior to being
told base Higgs attempts to trick us
into blowing up a safehouse
but luckily we threw the bomb in the
Black Sea and saved everyone which
allowed fragile to explain what happened
when she carried a bomb I followed a
delivery truck and somehow managed to
carry the bomb to safety but heaps had
been on to me from the start
he caught me red-handed outside the
gates nuke still cradled in my arms like
a child
fragile was caught by Higgs attempting
to get the original bomb out of the city
to punish her for disobeying him he gave
her a choice to run and save herself
from the imminent void out or take the
bombs far away from the city and be a
hero she chose the latter but there was
a caveat to Higgs his punishment she
must run through time fall unprotected
he gave her a mask to save her face but
the rest of fragile wasn't so lucky it
withered and became old making those
micro bye ops she's always eating so
much more important to her you are a
goddamn hero he did the right thing
without a moment to catch our breath the
next random action takes place a sudden
whirlwind like storm picks up Sam and
sends him back you ready for this -
World War one I promise I'm not making
this up the entire segment is a boss
fight against Clifford Unger the man we
saw in our BB dreams but this Clifford
is hell-bent on regaining his BB and has
a gang of skeletor's to help luckily
though Sam is a badass and kills
Clifford just in time for the storm to
end and bring him back to the present
day now back in present tense Sam finds
out he was gone from merely a few
seconds and not the hours he thought he
was there next hour Sam meets mama a
brilliant scientist who is trapped in
one room for the rest of her life and
here's why yep
she has a child who's a BT but somehow
they are still connected by the
umbilical cord in a gruesome flashback
it is revealed during a void out mama
who was heavily pregnant was trapped
under rubble for days and gave birth via
incomplete c-section while
simultaneously being crushed to death
somehow this harrowing event gave her
the ability to see her own child and
keep her here in the living world
instead of the beach
mama informed some about a brilliant
scientist he needs to go visit Lochner
but get this they are twin sisters so
off sam trots to visit Lochner but she
simply doesn't trust him Sally tries to
reunite the sisters to show how
trustworthy he is but mama just simply
won't leave her child after hours and
hours of procrastination mama creates a
weapon which cuts umbilical cords
allowing the undead to finally reach the
afterlife and leave the limbo beaches
the first bTW they try this on is Mama's
baby and yeah I cried a little bit here
[Music]
[Music]
after another Higgs bossfight mama a
strap to Sam's back and they go to find
her sister but when they arrive
mama is revealed to have died giving
birth but her connection to her twin
sister and the tie to her dead daughter
kept her in this land of the living
now that the siblings are back together
mama dies but for reals is this time
they were in fact conjoined twins at
birth and had such a close bond they
could speak to each other with entire
state between them the story heavily
suggests that they are in fact one
person split into two bodies and this is
embodied by the moment lakhna blinks and
the eye color of both siblings are
revealed before we can get our head
around all this sam's be bead is taken
away from him he is getting so close to
his bridge baby that he named the little
bugger lu lu and that's when we get to
know this guy dead man a person made up
from a blend of stem cells and dead
individuals the game sort of glosses
over this but it's implied that he's
some sort of frankenstein creation dead
man tell Sam that his BB is too close to
the land of the living and will soon
become a real baby and immediately die
in a few days to stop this he must
perform an operation so Sam reluctantly
agrees Sam goes back out into the world
without a BB which makes it far more
difficult by the way with our magic
necklace reconnect in the United States
of America internet and now we could
finally have our baby back we meet dead
man on a mountaintop covered in snow but
we shall not question how this big lad
got all the way up here I mean it took a
fully trained part of three days oh well
video games I suppose before Sam can see
Lu another chiral storm sends Sam
BB and Deadman back to World War two
this time yet again to face Clifford
Unger during the war sequence dead man
gives back BB and during the final
battle with Clifford Sam snatches his
dog tags and subtly we're back in the
real world again dead man explains his
wierd stem cell Frankie Stein thing
where the real information comes from
those dog tags which allow us to
understand Clifford's past a former
military captain who served in many wars
he was so good at what he did he never
lost a man in battle he always brought
them home so
Clifford may be a military badass trying
to gun us down but his heart is in the
right place next up Sam transports
mummers body to Hartman first we should
note that momma's body is not
necrotizing and that's why Hartman
wanted to run tests on her so Sam
climbed up another snowy mountain and
meet Hartman but he's already dead but
not for long so how the hell do we
explain this one Hartman dies every 21
minutes due to a complication with his
heart which is literally heart shaped by
the way Hartman undertook surgery mid
operation the area lost power due to
avoid out killing Hartman he spent the
next 21 minutes back on the beach with
hundreds of people who died in the same
moment he watched on as his wife and
child walked into the sea but before he
could rescue them the power came back on
in the hospital resuscitating him he was
dragged back into the land of the living
Hartman's life changed that day and now
he would happily give his life to find
his family on the beach so every 21
minutes he allows himself to die to give
himself three minutes on the beach he's
so devoted to his family he's died
almost a quarter of a million times but
cannot find his loved ones yet quick we
should lighten the mood
along with Mama's body Sam also
unwittingly brought along with him his
mother's umbilical cord yeah it's weird
just go with it from Mama's body and the
umbilical cord Hartman proclaims he
understands what's going on which is
good because nobody else understands
what the hell is going on
basically Kyrie Liam can be found in
Mama's body which is why she is not
necrotizing and carry Liam is in bridges
umbilical cord which allows her to go to
the beaches but Bridget's is ulting T
it's off the charts sometime later
Hartman deduces that Bridget get this is
an extinction entity and things get
really messed up now how did the
dinosaurs died out that would be by an
extinction entity what happens in the
under Thor man yep you've guessed it
they died via an extinction entity well
death stranding tells us there has been
five extinction entities in the history
of the world
and Allah fails because something
survived in the current world only human
beings and crypto buyouts have survived
to this point on by the way the five
flying figures you see throughout the
game but those are the previous
extinction entities watching on I
thought that was a pretty cool touch
Hartman then hits us with the facts it's
highly likely that a Malay is the next
extinction entity so be prepared armed
with this new information Sam finally
crosses America and reconnects everyone
huzzah hooray but it's short-lived
because eggs arrives and admits to
secretly helping us complete the network
so I could do this
brainwash a Malay into merging all and
then Bob beaches together by the chiral
network some literally just finished and
then he'll wipe out humanity in the
sixth extinction
Sam is quickly thrown into a huge boss
fight against this this thing he takes
it down of course cuz he's a badass
Higgs manages to escape and takes Emily
with him GG's on the butt slap physics
here I'm impressed but he tells Sam
exactly how to find him on the beach and
then mortally wound bebe this little guy
won't survive this fragile uses her
spiky coat and insta travel skills to
get Sam to the beach and then we have an
epic face-off between Sam and Higgs
resulting in some slow-motion face punch
muscle combat-style beautiful Sam wins
the epic battle of the ages and he's
done it defeated eggs and saved the
world he gets the girl this must be the
end and can I just comment on the weird
tension between Sam and his sister it
doesn't look like brother-sister love
it's really strange the last time I ran
with my sister across a beach I pushed
her into the sea but anyway the final
death stranding has been averted
everyone lives happily ever after roll
the credits oh wait wait wait there's
loads more to go through oh we're still
growing Emily decides to come clean
about everything but yes again before we
can get the real truth about things
something else happens over the next
hill on the beach is none other than
dead president Brigitte joined by her
second-in-command
die hard man can we all agree that name
is ridiculous and then Clifford walks
out of the sea by the looks of things
all the beaches are beginning to
converge as Higgs proclaimed and then
yet again before we get answers Emily
throw Sam off a cliff to repatriate back
to the land of the living Sam awakes in
a safe house and he's told to walk all
the way back to the beginning of the
game and be serious yes all the way back
across America to get answers so of
course we did it because after 35 hours
we all want closure Sam must bring back
crypto by oats for fragile who is almost
dead after using her powers to fast
travel everyone except Sam hmm
video game logic on the way back Sam
must avoid unreal amounts of BT's in the
worst time fall imaginable only to be
hit with another stone
this time he is sent back to the Nam to
Vietnam to face Clifford and the
skeletor's of one last time
after besting him we get hit with some
more truth bombs are you ready for this
as we suspected Clifford is a great man
a war hero a loving father to BB and
after his wife fell ill he was told by
his old friend his son Bibi was going to
be taken away and he would never see him
again die Hardman gives Clifford five
minutes to escape clifford then decides
to kill his own wife to sever the link
and took Bibi but sadly his plan failed
badly shot by security Clifford was
dying and took Bibi in his arms removing
the pod to hold his son for the first
and last time as time froze Sam realized
the baby was him Sam was the Bibi
Clifford has been searching for
of course these loving moments are
usually followed with grief and yeah it
happens here president strand comes in
and orders die hard man to kill Clifford
die hard man couldn't pull the trigger
so Bridget helps they didn't realize
that baby Sam was taken out of the pot
and the bullet killed both Clifford and
baby Sam guilt-stricken Bridget went to
the beach to resuscitate Sam making him
a repatriate in the process now outside
the pod president strand decided to
raise him as her own son little does she
know that going to the beach to rescue
sound would in fact allow all dead
beings to rejoin the living world she
unwittingly started the death stranding
so the scar we saw early on now has a
key meaning can Sam stop the final
stranding the extinction event to end
all extinction events he travels to the
beach to talk to his sister but then we
get another shocking twist Bridget and a
male are not mother and daughter like we
first thought they are in fact the same
person due to her cancer Bridget's soul
was not hauled with her body making two
parts of the same being as her body with
it Bridget told everyone of her daughter
to hide this fact which also explains
why a male only appears as a holographic
form in the real world and now the final
decision a male allows Sam to decide the
fate of the world kill her and give
humanity more time to live while at the
final stranding
tough choice but I personally let the
world burn and let her walk into the sea
oh you can't you can't do that it isn't
a choice after all you cannot kill a
Malay instead some must hug his sister
his mother whatever she is now this
moment of compassion is the only thing
preventing extinction like you a Malay
doesn't want to destroy humanity but she
knows it's her only purpose in life I
mean she previously begged Sam to kill
her to stop Armageddon so ultimately she
doesn't want to kill everyone I think
sort of so she decides to stay on the
beach for as long as she can but reminds
us that the sixth and final extinction
will happen it's inevitable and then the
credits roll again we finished yeah you
know we haven't finished really Sam is
literally pulled from the beach by all
his friends he's made on this adventure
so far fYI they use the umbilical cord
and other items to access the beach from
here die Hardman removes his mask and
becomes the new President of the United
States and after the press conference he
breaks down in front of Sam explaining
how he shot the man he loved Clifford
that's platonic love by the way don't
read too much into that some hits die
hard man with this line
nobody wants a president who acts like
they're immortal and if you're not
scared of death how can you fail you
life it's a pretty good line to say to a
president finally disaster strikes Lu is
proclaimed dead the BB we loved for so
long is no more and Sam must retrace his
steps from the first mission of the game
and incinerate his baby to prevent
another void out come on
on mass delivery in a show of compassion
dead man removed Sam from his binds to
the UCA allowing Sam to remove Lou from
the chamber without breaking the law
which of course he does and tries to
resuscitate Lou one last time and guess
what it failed
no I'm kidding he did it Lou is a real
baby all naked and cold the pair go
outside and feel real rain once again
without the fear of time fall and to end
this story Lou is actually revealed to
be a girl so little Lou is actually
little Louise now disconnected from the
chiral network Sam is free to live his
life with his daughter and that ends
death stranding it
[Music]
you
[Music]